now this story
it may ruffle some feathers
for impact
i mean it's it is what it is you know
people got mad i called out robert
kiyosaki but all i'm doing is reading
articles and giving my opinion so here's
an article that i saw and i said
you know who likes drama oh i like some
drama i want drama for your mama girl
here's this article i said we gotta
bring it up
there's people that are gonna agree with
this and there's people like how dare
you
how rude what is this full house
anyway yeah
you got something
so here okay without without uh without
ruffling the feathers too much let's get
into this story
this is from the motley fool here are
three things that legendary personal
finance guru dave ramsey gets really
really wrong about retirement savings
okay so this article brace for impact is
about to call out dave ramsey okay
so about to call you out dawg i can just
see the headline right so he's a
personal finance personality he's been
out there he's definitely an og remember
the ogs an og in this and he's got some
great advice no
doubt no dignity no doubt he certainly
has got some great advice about paying
back debt but this article basically
says you know his advice that he always
talks about in retirement planning yeah
you know all that stuff he talks about
investing rut ro
i don't think so bro oh that's awesome
so they said that he leaves a lot to be
desired and here are the three worst
pieces of retirement advice that he
gives welcome to watch
mojo
so number one
this isn't like crazy controversial but
here they say
you know he's a big proponent of mutual
funds yeah and this article goes on to
say
he's wrong about mutual funds and you
should probably maybe want to look into
index funds etfs or just individual
stocks okay
dave ramsey recommends mutual funds over
etfs etf stands for exchange traded
funds david because mutual funds are
designed again they've invested
over the long term it's possible to
outperform the market by selecting the
right funds it's a basket of funds
diversified approach you know i've
invested in mutual funds i've invested
in index funds dabbled with etfs got
some individual stocks you know sort of
personal preference what i always say as
long as you're putting money in the
market and you're giving it a go for the
long term and you're not trading while
you're drunk things are gonna work out
all right but this article goes on to
say but etfs can also be invested for
the long term too that dave ramsey
doesn't agree so while you have the
option of trading them like a stock
that's sort of the benefit of etfs if
you want to take anything about this you
could sell them like a stock hey i got
to eat the app boom we're trading we're
trading we're trading we're trading so
basically dave ramsey's not a fan of
that he's a more fan of a mutual fund
so you could trade in my stocks but you
don't have to do that you could also
still do buy and hold what can you also
do david
bye
and
hold what's the famous crypto thing for
buy and hold
a chell i don't know where i know these
terms i just know where you're going
yeah there you go sometimes you're going
to guess sometimes you're going to guess
right here's something wrong
basically they say you don't have to
invest in an etf that just tracks the s
p 500 you can choose a growth etf a
dividend etf or even etfs that follow
specific industries or sectors like
marijuana as an example or healthcare
industries bottom line is they're saying
number one
it's arguable that mutual funds are way
better than etfs all right so maybe
you're a mutual fund investor maybe
you're an index fund investor maybe
you're a
you know target date investor and you're
401k it's all good this isn't anything
crazy no beef with dave ramsey on that
oh certain intro it's because it'd be
like a dave ramsey being an old school
dude and it's just like i like what i
know
because he's maybe 65 is that 94 i don't
anyone a year older that's my impression
of paul too yeah
paul's 40. yeah i know exactly
all right maybe that let's let's circle
back to the old the oldness okay
number two this is what they say dave
ramsey gets wrong about investing
that you can earn a 12 average
annual rate of return okay there's
basically saying ramsey's 12 reality is
based on simple average returns of the s
p 500 which he reports as 11.6 percent
from 1928 to 2020 this is what i would
call inside baseball we won't get too
caught up into it but something to think
about simple average returns aren't
exactly the most accurate way to measure
how your investments perform so maybe
they're saying that 12
return isn't the truth because on
average the s p 500 stock market returns
about 10
and after inflation it might be closer
to eight all good they're basically
saying check your math dave ramsey check
yourself before you wreck yourself
that's on dave ramsey but here's the
there's the more controversial one the
first two
are investing and this is where dave
ramsey catches a lot of slack for all my
dave ramsey friends out there
they say where he says that you should
pay off all your non-mortgage you know
housing debt
before
investing for retirement basically dave
ramsey argues essentially
that you should do the following before
you start investing pay off all your
debt except for your mortgage all of it
credit cards car student loan debt is
sort of like high interest stuff maybe
certainly high interest but he's also
saying low interest everything
everything pay it all off
accept your mortgage okay
the controversial one is your
college loans that's because something's
more than your mortgage like well the
amount might be no your college loans
aren't necessarily more than your
mortgage maybe probably i mean depending
on where you're going
but a lot of times your college loans
might be closer to like four five six
percent and the stock market returns you
know closer to ten percent all right so
they're saying that's what he says to do
but here's the problem
you know we talked about earlier on the
show that it might take you 20 years on
average to pay off
your college debt yeah so you're gonna
wait 20 years until you're in your early
to mid 40s before you start investing
that's sort of the exact opposite of
what you should do if you want to have
that compound interest on your side
compound interest eighth wonder of the
world so basically what they're saying
is during that time you'd be missing out
on all your employer 401k matches which
is literally free money by the way if
your employer offers a 401k take that
with the match okay
because you'll be losing on a chance to
earn returns in the stock market so you
should absolutely prioritize debt and
saving for emergencies no doubt but not
necessarily at the expense of your
retirement funds so essentially you
don't risk free money for your 401k and
you're already to pay off debt you use
money you have to make those debt moves
so basically they're calling them out
they're saying look dave here are three
things you're getting wrong
your whole love affair with mutual funds
maybe not so much maybe that's not the
best approach maybe etfs or index funds
are better i challenge you to a duel
over over this number two
i think your math is kind of off twelve
percent seems aggressive you know they
say
um you know future
uh returns are not uh uh not based on
past past performances are not uh
indicator or future returns that all
that yes so he's saying yeah no they are
there they are
number three
uh that you should pay off all your
non-mortgage debt before investing so
here's my take on dave ramsey my two
cents here's my two cents okay
um
you said he's the og
right yeah let's use that you said okay
he's an og he's an og you know
so you know what og stands for
i mean i know og stands for original
gangster yeah okay so in the personal
finance space
you know he's certainly the original
gangster but you know what og could also
stand for oh boy what old guy old guy
old guy
oh maybe an old game
ramsey voice let's hear it
i don't like any i don't know what's
going on but i don't like it
get off my lawn
right so look bottom line is i have
immense respect for dave ramsey he's
actually one of the you know
my motivators i see what he's doing i'm
like alright cool it's dope i can kind
of do something like that but something
a little bit more for me
but basically what this article is
saying is essentially look everything he
says is not
the gospel so
do with it what you will for my dave
ramsey friends out there we're still
friends
from my dave ramsey detractors you're
entitled to your opinion but respect to
dave ramsey but bottom line is pay off
your debt save that money start
investing
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broke